when Captain Marvel came out and
introduced the scroll everybody got
really excited thinking that Marvel was
setting up a secret and invasion for
down the line but when Marvel came out
Marvel Studios decided to hit us with a
huge twist and instead of having the
scroll be bad guys just like they have
been all this time in the comics they
made them good and sadly everybody's
hoped for a Secret Invasion in the near
future kind of went out the window
however given some lines that were
dropped in spider-man fire from home we
have reason to believe that a Secret
Invasion is coming to the MCU and could
be coming pretty soon how's it going
everybody it's Warren and in this video
we're gonna talk about how spider-man
fire from homes set up a Secret Invasion
storyline to come into the MCU but with
a huge twist also if you would like the
chance to win a Captain America shield
and Iron Man helmet and Infinity
Gauntlet or another Marvel Legends item
be sure to subscribe to my channel to
enter my giveaway I'll be picking three
new winners at four hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers also if you are
trying to avoid spoilers for spider-man
far from home you should click away now
this is your official spoiler alert
so in the post credits scene for
spider-man fire from home we learned who
we thought was Nick Fury and Maria Hill
was actually Talos and his wife Nick
Fury and Maria Hill were off on vacation
but what this showed us is that the
scroll can successfully blend in and
take over characters in the MCU
however unlike Secret Invasion the
scroll and shield are working together
but it still seems like the secret
invasion is starting however it is not
the scroll that are invading but the
Kree and spider-man far from home Nick
Fury or Talos mentions that cells of
Kree elion now inhabit the earth so what
we basically have here is create sleeper
cells if you're unfamiliar with what a
sleeper cell is it's a secret group of
terrorists or agents that remain
inactive within a target population
until they are ordered to act so
essentially we have crea are on the
earth blending in with people around
waiting for orders in Captain Marvel we
learned that there aren't just blue Kree
but there are actual Kree that look like
humans these are known as pink Kree and
they look just like humans for example
Jude Law's character in Captain Marvel
Yan rigazzi paint Kree if no one told
you that he was a Kree you would think
that he was a human so what Talos said
and spider-man far from home was
there are Kriel ike this that looked
like normal humans inhabiting the earth
right now and what this basically does
in the MCU is sets up a reverse secret
invasion where the Kree are the ones
that are invading the earth and not the
scroll a lot of time has passed between
the events of Captain Marvel and the
events of Avengers endgame there has
been plenty of time between the two
events for a Kree to secretly rise in
power in organizations such as shield
and not just shield but other government
organizations as well and maybe even
sword all part of a plan to invade
infiltrate and eventually take over the
earth now at the end of Captain Marvel
Ronan said that he would be seeing
Captain Marvel again however he died in
guardians of the galaxy but in Guardians
1 the Nova Corps was speaking with the
Kree about Ronan's extreme actions and
the Kree didn't seem too apologetic
about what he was doing so perhaps there
are other career addict lists out there
who don't want peace but actually want
to invade other planets including earth
and we also don't know what happened to
yon raagh after the events of Captain
Marvel could he be the one to come back
seek vengeance on Captain Marvel and
lead a Kree invasion of the planet earth
we may have to wait until Captain Marvel
to to find out however it does seem like
this line and spider-man far from home
does set up a reverse Secret Invasion
especially since it is Talos a Skrull
who mentions the Kree cells he does seem
to be worried about some sort of
infiltration from the Kree
so be sure to let me know in the
comments down below if you think
Tallis's line in spider-man far from
home is setting up a reverse Secret
Invasion down the road in the future of
the MCU and also be sure to comment with
your favorite superhero or villain like
this video and subscribe to my channel
so you can enter my giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to the
MCU as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff